YouTube actually says you yeah cuz
normally what will happen is you'll hit
it and even though you're - yeah I saved
the street appreciate your brother thank
you thank you that's what helped me
through my transition man help me dude
it says this I'm not I ain't saying
nothing until you to say yeah good
alright alright and we are finally live
sorry guys
well welcome to the Isle of I guess and
the Lords of gaming dotnet episode
number 125 and it's another glorious
Sunday we're back at the roundtable on
the Lord's Day I'm very excited about
our special guests and we've got gears v
number one on Xbox Live - stranding TGS
impressions borderlands 3 release and
new streaming competitors to discuss so
we gonna get right into it I want to
introduce the Lord who the ILP had the
pleasure of meeting in the flesh at e3
2019 not only is this Lord one of the
most personal and passionate content
creators in the game but truly
represents the gold standard of video
production all done with detailed
technical analysis and vintage Hollywood
flair introducing the creator and host
of the Cole Eastwood youtube channel and
panelists of the RDX podcast one of the
best graphic designers in the game and
the Lord whose thumbnail game is so
tight that everyone in the community has
googled his work at least once by
accident more than just gameplay and
making his long awaited debut into the
realm of the Lords creep with me through
the Xbox hood lunatic with the vids call
him Lord Coe Eastwood how you doing a
second time I'm doing really well that
was that was a really good intro and
yeah yeah you got a couple of Easter
eggs in there for me appreciate it a
little not too my namesake
yeah
oh yeah that's really good not many
people know that one let us see how
Lourdes Lourdes brat basement basement
arcade at Lourdes salty cuz I make a lot
of appearances when I was able to catch
those I cut some nuggets ah are you
doing there good to have you in a
Romulan really yeah it was spend a long
time coming i I just decided just to
move a couple things is to get on here
because it had to happen thank you yeah
I mean I knew I wanted to be on here
even before we met at e3 but that was
like a pure pleasure to meet King David
and and then you know it's like we're
all gonna meet next year right
yes when I'm when I met Cole yeah when I
saw his face his face looks just exactly
full you know not exactly like you know
like I'm like you know you look just
like your are you mean I see you is I
gotta take a picture attending please
please please please oh man there's a
picture and being him intimidate and you
know all these other tall dudes and I'm
I put my arms around David and I'm on my
tippy toes literally literally I got to
shake your you guys are on the security
right it's like right before we get to
the building they put on uniform you're
gonna be serving there
yeah cults face and everything was going
on and I'm gonna tell you man the the
pure joy across his face the amazement
on things that was going on um it in
night's you inside because you get to
see the joy again like this faint if you
enjoy that you had the first time yes I
was like you having those guys so you
guys take it's cool to get the faces to
everybody you don't say so you're glad
to have you in a realm called long
overdue brother
yeah oh we already have we don't have
the Four Horsemen of gaming I don't know
whether not least I shot the Lord's
table now fortunately you could not
bigger better the Lord should be back in
the round the scheduling work is on him
right now but hopefully we get him back
soon
Oh shadow did dizzy with the two dollars
he would check well well well another
week is still no these kids both in the
building he said they treated us like
Squires yes they did yes they did I
think you're onto something and you know
um
shut up to you I hope you feel better
you know I love you bro and I really
hope everything goes well no doubt
salute but you still in the round
Michaels with the cold most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror Lord of reviews and the heart
of the young wolf mommy
Lord addict how you doing sir they're
pretty good uh just quick question on
King or is there gonna be like the fight
stuff this morning yes you know it's
funny you know it was because you knew
what happened yesterday
don't let me bring the throw it out
bring the fraud of the Lord because I
have no idea what happened
be good of it I've been um playing
Borderlands final fantasy a I still been
playing gears but you've been doing it
for some reason
no okay first of all adjusting all the
boxes is gone right so Emmys was this
what you saw a is a little small snippet
right a whole giant room in the back and
had to remove all those boxes and put
them inside the shed I still got boxes
back that I'm still moving inside the
shed and um you know taking extra boxes
and putting them instead so when I get a
chance to play I'm playing like you know
for at least an hour gears and I wanna
say I'm gonna do everything in Gears
right I wanna I wanna upgrade stuff I'm
gonna look places I'm gonna see stuff
because it's a so you can only sightsee
ah he he well if he's place up he's good
about not spoiling it while please you
see why your sites you know I'm like
check Facebook or something give a shot
man we got about ten seconds away from
dropping everything on call so at this
point just open my eyes I need a
multiple people to play Borderlands and
the only people I play border lies with
was demon areevo Oh like like when I
joined the part they're like that's a
stranger no no so he's been bought of
lands and on what you call for your
gears that's it borderline as it gears I
played like hours of that xscape
oh that's what's up that's what's up how
the phone would escape no doubt what
began with no one else alright you go
stop guilted us now I feel bad all right
I gotta get rocket to schedule
permitting we gonna rock man - I got
your back
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka the XS gamer whoo the
Lord of combat sports king of the
statues who demands nothing less than
their premium experience it is the
leader of the fraud alert movement ooh
late we love it I'm doing fantastic
um okay so one day yo King why is no
combat talk going up lifter listen guys
last night's fight with Tyson Fury was a
person picking the tomato camp first not
only is his little fake title as lineage
champion some crap that they're putting
along so you guys can just tune in
thinking he's some part of the
heavyweight championship know the facts
of the matter is he lost his belts due
to his drug abuse and his inactivity
alright so the fact that this man lost
his belts is because he was unfit to
have the belts you're not fit to be the
champion so stop running around talking
about you the champion because you and
your rehab run all right you only have
run right now and you're picking tomato
cans you got knocked out by the real
champion now you struggling with these
guys and your face looking all beat up
you're looking all hurt
I truly can't wait for you to fight the
ante Wilder so he can stretch you and I
can do a combat listen did this footage
out there of the when they do the ring
count now if anybody knows boxing when
you go to a live boxing event there's a
woman or man that's outside the ring
there's great to assist the ref in an
end of a knock-down that person stands
up and starts the count just think if
the ref gets distracted or
understand what's going on in the ring
that person is there to have the count
you may notice a ref may look outside
and continue to count from the person
that's outside um Tyson Fury was counted
out in that fight he continued to go on
and we already know right okay not
taking anything away from that part he
came he fought the champion with a great
fight my thing is this guy is fighting
tomato cans and he wants maximum
viewership what it would do before back
in the days when a weather was fighting
would associate the name Floyd
Mayweather in anything that they're
doing and it will get clicks and it
would get likes and we get follows and
they get a trend let's entice a fury for
it absolutely and you know what no
disrespect to Oswald wild oh you are a
decent fighter okay
rocky and Apollo Creed was fighting
yesterday you would have got a combat
toy worried the of me defeat the reason
why this ain't worthy I'm not gonna tell
you to go watch something it's like
watching paint dry you know you don't
want to tell nobody to do that so it's
um I tell you you know UFC is actually
killing it right now we're actually
putting out fights that are worth your
viewing pleasure yeah that was a good
one yeah you had me turning into UFC and
I don't know anything about UFC guys so
when I tuned in and I see somebody like
cowboy or something like that and I'm
just like okay okay and I'm just no good
fighters I just no good technique when
it comes to that stuff and I would like
you know other guys to help me along
with that with the names of the people
but um listen don't waste your time
don't worry about it
that's the combat so I'll come back
attic we're all in it gears all week
okay that's it that's it anytime I got a
chance to play gears that's all I wanted
to play I've waited for this game for so
long to play this game it's no need for
me to rush off and play something else
this is what I
wanna play i haven't played no destiny i
have and i don't jump in party chat i
wanna soak the game up because i play
part 4 and part 4 was so good for me
okay the playing par 5 this is fantastic
so no we have the lord of the
cooperative experience and gaming ninja
himself the shinobi lore Cognito
spreading that realm real listen to rum
and ILP not only what you want to hear
but what you need to hear same thing as
your mat gears um borderlands got a
touch briefly you know i'm saying well
get into that i know it's one of our
topics and of course destiny prepping
for all the stuff that is coming you
know i'm saying so that's pretty much it
for me but um now that we got into what
the lords have been playing i want to
start off with lord colt his video game
system history his journey as a graphic
designer and cartoonist and what led him
from youtube to what one of arguably one
of the most popular and best
r-tx xbox podcasts that we know our TX
of course so on look old man let's start
from the very beginning like what was
some of the first video game systems you
had and what got you to gave me
alright here's where i tell everybody
how old I am
I started out guys yes talk about it
Gekko yes about 20 minutes so I don't
know this you educate the youth cult
educate him let me tell you all you
young bucks just going on to be a great
world right I started out with the
Intellivision eighties I never owned an
Atari and in the in the late 80s my
parents got me a Nintendo and that's
when I became a junkie so the best part
about my video game history was around
the time the Super Nintendo came out my
little brother made fun of me said that
everyone called me Nintendo freako at
school and I was just starting high
school so I ditched gaming for like
almost 10 years so it's yeah it's really
I mean I just I don't only started
getting a girlfriend or two and hanging
out got a job got a car became cold East
would go easy
and yeah it's crazy so around the time I
got married you know bill house had a
couple kids I told myself I'm out of
college I need to get a video game
system so I bought an old OG xbox mmm
when everyone was buying the Xbox 360 I
had that for like six months I said
forget this I got to go back I got to go
with everyone else so I got a 360 and
when I got GTA 4 this is 2008 when GTA 4
came out I was it was over I was like I
was like in gaming like no other I
missed like the whole late 90s early
2000s era like I missed the Nintendo 64
I mean I played them a little bit at
friend's house but it was crazy I
there's just like this black hole yeah
of time where I didn't get that's so
interesting let me let me back up just a
second shot did Ashley look into our
super chat talk about his nickname we
will get it to that further yeah I kind
of alluded to it because it is intro we
will get to that little girl
um but I won't go back so basically
first of all you dropped a bomb I can't
let you get past a bomb if you drop with
the Intellivision cake King oh yeah that
was oh yeah so I know I'm proud of my
age I'd know about that one so then you
kind of you kind of didn't transition
into NES and it was so NES was that was
to start the of the beginning of that
gap was that the last console before did
he get back to the to the OG xbox uh
well I mean we had the NES I didn't
realize it but remember that there was
the video game crash the Atari in the
Intellivision like there was a gap where
people didn't have really play games at
home we went to the arcades and I didn't
do that because if you remember back in
the mid to late 80s like it was
expensive to play on an arcade so it's
when um they put out all those ET games
and that's when the crash happened from
Matar I mean I had a friend who had a
literal this is a shout-out to the king
I had a friend who had a literal paper
out and he would use his paper out money
to play paperboy on arcade at the gas
station so yeah so we we just got in the
Super Nintendo and it played like f-zero
Street Fighter and I just didn't enjoy
it as much sandy ass
and the end the men of my little brother
who's like you know a year and a half
younger me came in and he's like
everyone at school calls you Nintendo
freak oh and I'm like oh I was just I
felt so embarrassed now it did it did it
cut me deep so uh it did it really it
really got to me and so I right now I am
NOT a [ __ ] I am proud to be such a nerd
and play games and I'll tell people at
work I'm like you don't understand I go
it's like going to watch the best action
movie theaters except you are
controlling the characters
that's what video gaming is no doubt so
yeah I missed that whole gap like people
talked about Final Fantasy Resident Evil
Starcraft World of Warcraft stuff like
that I have no know like understanding
of that era of gaming
it was beast but now let's get you back
you can now come but now what I want
again I want to touch back what was the
draw you said you got the OG xbox well
your first out to 360 but what when was
it something in the back your head did
you see something that you thought you
know what I need to pick it back up and
game pick that controller like yeah I
mean I had I had just had my second kid
and I felt like you know I I I've done
enough in life because I didn't want to
have a gaming console to distract me
through college and all that stuff and I
thought I I gotta play this stuff and
and my buddy gave me GTA san andreas
mm-hmm and when I was in high school one
of my absolute favorite movies was
menace to society and I felt like and I
felt like that game that movie is like
the most perfectly cinematically shot
movie ever like I don't know why it
doesn't get accolades for the way that
movie was shot it's amazing class mazing
and I felt like I was playing boys in
the hood and Menace society when I
played that game and if and the cool
thing about it is I I played legend
zelda on nes back when I was a kid I've
realized that GTA san andreas was like a
Legend of Zelda in gangster rap
I may add opportunites which I didn't
know that term RPG elements back you
know 2007 or just NATO right over when I
was playing that absolutely loved that
game and GTA 4 was coming out and I'm
like I got to do it I told my wife I go
I gotta buy one of these 360s she goes
wait a month because the 60 gig one's
coming out I'm like you got back in the
basement awesome awesome story very
unique very unique I like that never
question to you is though obviously you
know there's a lot of graphic design and
cartoonists I mean we see the thumbnails
we see all the work you doing I had to
do the intro
even the Lords were guilty we did
question to you Cole is like was this
something you were always doing prior to
the YouTube thing like was that part of
the background I give us some some
background on the under graphic aspect
design aspect um I started graphic
design like around the time I got the
Xbox okay
so I was kind of doing that this stuff
for work and I had to do a lot of half
self teaching and then half of learning
from a couple people and so I just
always liked creating stuff so I made
some stuff on my youtube channel like
personal videos and I tried to produce
them and once I got into gaming I
watched a lot of people on you too Mike
now I wish I could do that but back then
when we had the Xbox 360 you couldn't
make a youtube channel less you had a
really good PC and you had a capture
program or capture card so I just didn't
do it and once the Xbox one came out and
you could record I said alright I gotta
make a channel I got to do this and so I
tried to pour everything that I could
like voiceover graphics editing and yeah
I mean I have a pass with video editing
even on on video tape like I've worked
with machines and stuff and it's come a
long way I've always wanted to do this
it shows because the deal what this day
is like right off the top I mean I
remember the first time I came across
one of your videos and I was just like
man this is a different level like this
is and there's no disrespect to all the
other content creator and I love all
these guys
but the work that you do Cole is it
truly kid you know under model it's like
when you go to the movies and you hear
in a world where that's cool Eastwood's
video like slowly what video is
something differently let me you know
cog knows there's only three people that
i religiously make sure that i must tune
in to watch its cult its dealer in his
ran you know it's not an arrow it is
whenever you know whoever pops up first
is definitely I'm definitely gonna watch
it um only video that did not watch from
y'all three was the Gears of War video
that's right I went to everybody's chat
section names like Jason I am definitely
watching it later after I finish the
game but his stuff is exactly what it
you know it's very well done if you
wanna how to on how to put something
together this is just standing you
understand this is it's exactly the most
professional the cleanest and just very
damn good he said actually was talking
about a cult designing a gamer pic and
he says on the hood of his kids racing
team that he sponsors Luke you don't say
that that it's cool he sent me a picture
of he had me designed these two
grasshoppers holding assault rifles
because you said he served in the
military so he had me designed this logo
this is will me hood and it's got the
two grasshoppers holding an aka and an
m4 or whatever and he showed me this
picture of this I don't know it's
probably like four foot wide circle logo
a glossy vinyl wrapped on this hood of
this car I'm like holy crap I think it
was on the hood but like that is a for
me yeah I mean I turned him 50 bucks for
that logo you know I spent about four or
five hours on it you know it I loved
working on it but that was the ultimate
reward to say hey colt
look where your logo is I mean that it
it's awesome bro it's it's late back
communities giving up a lot of love
distracted by like coke is like the Bob
Ross of gaming design
Jonathan be the father super chat coat
went from writing game reviews on stone
tablets all the way to making YouTube
videos you've seen it all look it's a
look people love your work better and
we've see we've seen the gamer picks the
avatars all over the place van
tremendous tremendous work so now let's
get to the YouTube ever late how did
that get going like how did you get
started with that
obviously at Lucas asked and I've
already kind of alluded we're gonna I
want you to tell the people about the
code east of Monica and then of course
what led you to order yet so let's start
you two first
okay I mean I could skip all the
preamble and and it really started when
I made a destiny review video yes so I
really it's cool it's ok cool you still
don't you still allowed to come back
yeah yeah destiny I didn't like destiny
so I did a review and I didn't give it a
number anything I just talked about what
I I was a big Borderlands fan and
destiny just it went part of the way and
just stopped for me yeah so I decided to
make this review and try to put in my
production values into it got a thousand
views and all that's cool and so I did a
bunch of other stuff and I went like two
years getting on average like 50 views
to 250 views and I would spend hours on
videos and I just thought man you should
really have to scratch and claw your way
into YouTube there's millions of content
creators thousands and thousands of
top-tier video game content creators and
I'll fast I I had a couple successes I I
talked about why Dead Island 2 was it
coming and had like 50,000 views and I
mean you look at that next to all my
videos and like 50 views 250 views all
sudden there's live in two thousand
views and the next one is about 250
views like it was it was horrible
but fast forward to spring of 2017 and
dealer gaming messaged me and I was a
big fan of this guy cuz I used to watch
his videos twice a week like he put out
something every few days and I'd be at
work and I would sit my phone on my desk
and listen and watch his video while
he's driving around 4:00 to 6:00 right
loved his delivery loved his technology
just loved that he just told her how is
and he was just really good and he
didn't have no drama no drama dealer
just I'm here to talk about what you
need to know you're asking his questions
I've got the answers so I had commented
on one of his videos one day and he
messaged means to say colt your comment
has like 350 likes on my video and it's
like the top comment that's really cool
and I'm like oh my gosh dealer dealer
message so I said something back to him
and he goes hey man we need to talk
about why your videos aren't getting
viewed and I'm like okay just call me on
hangouts guess whose hangouts number cuz
he doesn't know if I'm a stalker and I'm
shoutout to dealer for being careful
around a guy named Cole so I'm at work
one day and he calls me on hangouts and
my boss and I sit across the room from
each other and he's talking to me he
starts to give me you need to do this
stop doing this make sure you're doing
this and this and this we talked for
about an hour I get off the phone and I
go I just talked to peeler Davie it's so
funny cuz we're all just regular dudes
yeah we're all just we're all just
putting out content for people that love
to hear about content and sometimes we
feel like we're talking to somebody is
way bigger than us and some you know
people are awesome so the crazy thing
was dealer had to talk with me once or
twice and the next two weeks my channel
changed and I mean it was unbelievable
he gave me a shout out one I did a video
and he said hey guys check out his Cole
Eastwood he's really good and it just it
was huge and it changed my life and I I
don't know how to tell people I don't
tell people this a lot and I've told
dealers several times dealer you changed
my life you made the difference where my
family and I have like extra spending
money we go on a couple extra trips I
took my wife with me to III went to fan
fests we spent the week in LA together
met you guys like it is absolutely
amazing and this this community
notwithstanding a couple of turds
absolutely outstanding I love it I'm
glad
I'm glad you said that because um you
know look we we're friends with everyone
on every community every side and I like
that the good is actually pointed out
for people sometimes they may get a bad
rep on occasion and I've heard this
story multiple times you know say a
reference to dissolute the dealing with
good friends in the realm and they hear
you say that and just you know we've
seen a time before me an addict I've
talked to some Indians even giving us
advice like Amon step you might game up
loyal you see the market like you know
there's things for us you know I'm
saying that he's done and he doesn't get
enough credit for that and I think if
people got a chance to really know him
and you know saying get behind you won't
forget all the BS and just talk gaming
he's really good do so I'm glad you said
that that is so many I just don't want
to forget oh wow will my hood Wow
with the $50 super chip brother thank
you so much I wish you had some work
behind again I would love to express it
well whatever you want to say just put
it in the chair okay
he's got a following statement this is
what a podcast should be great show
gentlemen thank you very much shout out
to the grounded gala Fonzarelli I can
confirm dealer and Co are both awesome
people and good friends and that's what
it's about man like at the end of the
day we're here for gaming and hear you
say that Wow so I mean that you know
once Fonz and I met in person a couple
weeks ago my family and I went to
Disneyland and fauns and I met on the
outskirts of where he lives and we were
just gonna stop at it in and out and
just meet we hung out for five hours
don't 1:30 in the morning that's himself
now it's like it's like Fonz and I went
to high school together
cuz we're a same age no we didn't even
we hardly even talked about gaming it
was amazing
oh yeah I could tell you for a fact I
mean I've always known Fonz was good
dude good people but then then we meet
in real life none of us is serial killer
just because neither one of you killed
each other don't mean not none of your
cereal I want you to tell the people cuz
I know I did a little spiel with your
intro but we got to get to it man
everyone says
tell us about the name how did he pick
the name so so is it true did I get it
right oh yeah you got her the maniac of
black mr. Snoopy swore yeah that deep
covers oh yeah also in the chronic album
yeah yeah they do use that same line
yeah back in the day like that was that
was my stuff yeah so I my first car the
car I had in high school was a Colt
there's a Colt heed oh yeah this little
hatchback kind of looked like it was
silver it looked like a DeLorean that a
pregnant woman would drive but I had
this massive sound system and it's so
bad that the the sound like the license
plate was gonna come off so uh yeah they
call people call me colt
they call me Colt bass and then they
started calling me snoop and then they
started calling me Cole Eastwood because
of that song so yeah it was yeah I heard
that I heard of it I would've shot I got
a shout-out all Bracke Bracke because
that's what I first got I was doing some
research and I was like oh I love code
now evil boy like like that people
understand that verse that was like
almost like early Snoop debut oh yeah
that was like that was snoops first big
appearance was on the Deep Cover song
yes and then he was he was halfway in
the chronic album and that's what's
upheld the doggy style album I mean I we
skipped school my four friends of mine
we skipped school on a snowy day and
drove down to the mall when it opened to
pick up doggy style Oh dog so that class
thing bro yeah we and I went home and
it's funny because I grew up listening
to like 80s and soft rock and stuff but
but gangster rap changed how I looked at
music and I skipped school to go get
that CD and we drove around with a
discman plugged into a radio in the end
my friends truck doing donuts around
while we're skipped to school listen to
that little opening baby he was killed
yeah you think I'm ready would did Nate
listen I love that lobster because
that's literally about top to snoop
versions of all time isn't that one to
Crete with me and the on number D G Pig
the one to ten therefore those are like
what
first heard that for the first time like
he made his mark man like go so loco
least with with the gangster rap
references dude Elvis man but we're
gonna ask you to ask every guest at the
round table we gotta ask you your top
five video game or franchises of all
time let's go okay um first one is Mass
Effect
I love the Mass Effect I love
Borderlands and fallout so those are my
big genres so it's really hard to top I
mean GTA san andreas probably my
all-time favorite game it's hard to go
back to now because it's so old but I
felt like it did everything you could
fly you could skydive you could ride a
bicycle lane actually you had to pump
the trigger to pedal the bike down the
sticky yeah that was awesome and a big
Red Dead Redemption fan I mean I just
like I love games I love him so much and
I don't know I probably play 20 hours a
week I do a podcast once a week I make a
video once a week I hardly sleep I'm too
old to be doing this but I love it we
love it that's what we do it right
absolutely so what you said Mass Effect
Grant F Red Dead did I mr. border pants
Borderlands and Fallout and fallout yeah
I did like a whole let's play of Fallout
for that no one watched I know exactly
who did watch a command do about you
before everybody else
what's he love fallout that is cookies
with tremendous gaming history so we got
a lot going on you know say so last
week's poll results in the people have
spoken to the question with the overall
positive reception and solid metacritic
score
regarding Gears 5 how critical was the
success of Gears 5 for the overall Xbox
game studio brand the winner
I will run away 3-way ILP poll at 69% is
the critical Xbox game studios prove
they can deliver high quality games with
momentum into next-gen coming that
second place at only 26% was that I'm
not impressed with Xbox game studios
it's really something other than halo
kids and Forza in the last place at a
close six percent less I don't care
until gears 5 fix their online service
group shout to all the lords who
participated in last week's poll Lord
Colt what do you think about this man
was gears 5 that critical do you agree
with the people uh that was so good it
was actually an emotional ride playing
that game yeah I loved it I loved it
I got to play it our early review I
played it the weekend before it came out
and it ran flawlessly there are
absolutely no problems there was one
problem dealer and I played much of it
co-op where a jack went to open his safe
and he kept a bump in it like he was
humping the safe and it was it was thing
where I was hosting so I hit start
reload checkpoint and loaded for like
eight seconds and we were right back to
where the battle finished and we told
Jack to go act safe but it's really
having problems right now but dang the
game was so good I I loved it I gave it
a really high score I gave it a nine
point five out of 10 or 95 it is it's
critical reading before it's critical
for the brand and for Xbox game pass or
Xbox game studios because it's one of
the best games that they've put out and
Xbox games tutors been around like a
whole year right ya know they have a
ways to go absolutely did smooth says
this game of the year I definitely think
it's gonna get game of the Year
nomination it's got two inch ahead of
Sakura it's got an inch ahead of
Resident Evil 2 which I don't know if
that is gonna be in there it's got an
inch ahead of death strandings is much
later everybody got a whole lot of work
to do with gotta love marathon ik
instead stranding I would love to throw
my money in with Kid smooth on Game of
the Year cuz I think he's got something
going there
I really do I know kids smooth puts out
he puts his neck out on the line yeah
for what I think is is you know
something like years being game of the
year is it should be a believable thing
and people are gonna hassle somebody
like kid or somebody like me for saying
something like that but you got to be
real this game was really well done
it had the emotional notes it it's one
of the best looking games in the whole
generation it's why I say one of the yes
people don't like to use the word with
it to get all sensitive which you say
that color but yeah I'm with you
I'm definitely with you I think that um
it's tremendous it should be up there
and the thing that I like about it is
that all just feature wise it's very
robust you know says it's doing a bunch
of things but you got the co-operative a
second-story got the single-player you
got horn you got all these molds man so
I think it definitely should be up in
the mix but that's what I got we gonna
get into these topics show Oh Lord King
well check it out right and shout out to
Randolph though on my man all right this
is how I came across like I tell you I
have my burgers fries and shake my deal
Iran and coke all right that's my joy
there's my go-to so I stick my hand out
my head out the sand playing gears and
um you know cuz like yo you know you
know topics for the week and I'm looking
at his leading and I watched a video and
what blew me away is is that again gives
five ultimate top for tonight and what
what makes it more amazing is that the
gears 5 regular edition made the list as
well so you know guess five ultimate was
in game pass and fortnight main it is a
free to play game
that means everybody got the fingers on
it
we already know the levels that
everybody's playing this game
relentlessly and the fact that gears
ultimate lead it out for the number one
position on Xbox Live isn't
iOpener for a game that so-called people
were saying that they don't know if it
was gonna be this they didn't know if it
was gonna be that it was so much doubt
it was so much speculation around the
single-player game my question is does
this surprise anyone and does this bode
well for the future of Xbox Live and
especially the fact that the the limited
amount of people in game pass is it a
limited amount of people now are they
not giving out numbers they are greater
than what we think it is obviously um
what it did happen is early week and it
was number one as right now it's portal
a well they didn't give up but that's it
live up-to-date join but it was number
one and I think you're making a good
point let's bring it back to coal um
like coal during that period when you
have gears 5 launch and obviously we
know 492 juggernaut that it is it's free
to play and everyone has fun it's just a
phenomenon like were you even surprised
that that gears was able to contend and
knock it out the spot even for that for
that period yeah I mean I'm all these
new games usually take top spot for a
little bit like Borderlands is right now
but yeah it shows the power a game pass
I don't know I get tired of people
talent sales
I've had people literally tell me on
social media they'd rather play the
version that has sold the most and play
the one that plays the best and looks
the best so I don't know that's kind of
the mentality of the way people look at
things so that their platform could be
held up higher than the other but I
don't know I it's just weird game IGN
gave Gears a 9 GameSpot gave it a 7 like
what's going on with oh man I'm I'm
trying not to get into the valley yeah
I'm totally trying to stay away from it
because I keep telling people reviews
don't matter like they are one tool they
are one tool that you need to use when
you decide to buy a game they're not the
be-all end-all so if a few outlets give
it
score which is what happened with gears
right it's not a big deal but when one
of them is heavily weighted on
Metacritic
yikes I guess for me my more
specifically she was like um in
reference to the connection with with
game pass right cuz obviously you know
we've heard conflict I want to say
conflicting some people feel you know
obviously we speak to the map piscatella
is the NPD guys we speak to a lot of the
devs they tell us how beneficial game
path is and how it creates engagement
but like you know some people do feel
like I don't know if this is the right
way microsomes going but do you feel
that the game pass impact has something
to do with that positively where it can
overtake something like a fortnight even
even if it's briefly or next much love
yeah yeah I mean definitely game passes
brought more people to games that they
would never play and it makes a massive
reach for something like gears 5 I've
seen people say I don't know if I'm
gonna try it yet or I'm gonna wait till
it goes on sale I'm like where's the
whole game pass exists like I mean
people people on PC I'm it's what I mean
at the very most is 10 bucks or 15 bucks
to get ultimate I give it a try for a
month some since I so once said I don't
know if I want to try Borderlands or
Gears first I'm like get them both get
Gears them in-game pass get Borderlands
for 60 bucks I'm just here to say the
game pass suck
[Music]
what do you feel about this I'll be it
briefly you don't say it what about
gears kind of being on the xbox live
most played list it's awesome
it's a great game it's deserving it's
really deserving it's it's a it's a fun
game lots of people love the the
multiplayer in the game so I mean it's
only fitting right that people are just
playing the heck out of it right now
hold entitlement I mean it doesn't
surprise me when my brand new game comes
out that's especially on the caliber of
Gears it'd be weird if it didn't I mean
snatch the the fortnight players for a
couple hours and then they went back
when they just because just because
we're not free-to-play don't mean game
passing a dollar for news right now
Olivia had to be flipping oh yeah that
what about like for a perspective of do
you think let's say cuz a lot of people
did jump in shot you know yo he bought
these don't even play xbox like that I
picked up ultimate was playing gears
we're streaming it so my question is do
you think this will help with them
retaining the subs or are you worried
that yo wants to get if they have a
quality game like a gears that once that
seek that you don't have the movement is
over that they'll kind of let it let it
go what do you feel about that I think
it's gonna be just like when I worked at
a dish people don't realize people
forget that they're in description yes
and you know many times I have to add
because I would you know I had to read
the the pretty much like the damage
control statement for so many times like
I memorized it like you know I
definitely understand ma'am you know we
can go through the routes we can get you
took off the subscription but but we
every fun it just it happens all the
time like you know think about all the
subscriptions people have right now and
how many you know you actually
unsubscribe to
it's a good point there's a good point a
lot of people you know you're in those
reoccurring subscription services I mean
even not it's something I'm there ea
axis it got a goat
Lord King what's going on topic brother
well you know listen I I want them to
continue this momentum going forward
Michael said you know it's nice to build
the house but you got to fill it up with
people right so let's let's let's let's
let's start filling it up with good
games going forward this is a Microsoft
Studios first real banger great and
let's let's keep it going let's let this
be the gold standard is a full robust
game that has multiplayer any way that
you want to play your multiplayer it
also has a board building like um you
can actually build up your own map and
actually descend and play it and you can
also play other people's maps this is a
robust full-fledged game single-player
multiplayer multiplayer horde PvE
versus you know it's a very well
thought-out map executed game and in the
beginning we were so afraid of what was
gonna happen
why didn't show this we was so critical
and questioning what was gonna go on and
the fact that it you know it debuted at
you know number one um that speaks
volumes to me I thought it resonated
well because game + game past is the
vehicle going forward for Microsoft
absolutely and you know that's just how
I felt about it is it like electron says
it's a really really good game so you
know I was very surprised I VIII I never
think anything is going to deter own
fortnight just in this current space so
even if it's for a brief period you know
I'm saying to me it's still impressive
and like you said you know I think game
passes the driver I think their whole
concern is getting people attached to
the service you know so I guess for me
I'm more curious of you know MPD or
September to see how that
correlations gonna work if um you know
as far as retainment that's clear
Eastern oh yeah that's what I want to
see I want to see how that goes off cuz
we've seen in the past you know saying
win state of decay see a thief things
like that you know that that helped
propel those to win MPD months so um I
think for Microsoft at this point I
think their whole thing is just get
everybody in on this service you have
quality games that's gonna attract them
and then kind of keep that momentum
going forward with a projects cloud and
hopefully scarlet you know just to keep
people locked in shut out to stitch with
the to our super chat this should be the
gold standard on every plant Perry
microphones biggest asset that they're
gonna have is you know let's let's not
forget that gears is a multiplayer game
yes and it's a good multiplayer game
it's not you know I might not have
enjoyed CPU but people still played see
thieves on game paths are you because
it's there yeah believe me miss um it
was this uh
Victor and we got the big boy we got no
no one more after the yeah it was a to
LA super touch the leuco for being part
of this community and also sorry you
know super chat let's listen I don't got
on my glasses I got a nice deck Shan
Shan and the reason why I'm gonna keep
having a zone because my eyes look like
needle got me up in the morning going on
on your screen at all and I'm gonna wear
these because making memes out of me I
appreciate you for picking me up there
addict help me out to if I miss anything
about you said it sewed up so I was
excited
ball game pass it is definitely true I
am super super captain game pass and I
just love the value that you get for it
you know poster a couple of things that
we're gonna talk about later the father
being petty David you'll never exceed
the Lord
you know me my man game is crazy okay
shout out to DJ segment oh my god gets
me all the time so look anchorman got me
a good tattoo so salute to those
brothers you already know so we gonna
get it to the next topic man Lord addict
what is going on man we had someone
reveal of a kijima game more information
correct look you got to stop I'm gonna
start laughing you can't so Kojima hmm
over there Kojima Productions at this
only you know they released a 50 minute
gameplay mm-hmm
you know people were saying with the
jima you know we like your game we just
want to see more on it and we saw more
[Laughter]
look man we might have to just go ahead
like I don't even think throwing this
game in the bushes is gonna be enough we
might have to we might have to go over
there and throw the entire business in
the ocean like like I just you know
what's funny
and I posted something on Twitter a
crazy idea choked out you know people
apparently you know they control
everything but you know I make a joke
and take this series I got people giving
me the address st. pull up and I'll just
first off wait wait yes okay after about
the third no there's about five or six
people did it after about the second or
third one I just muted everything I was
like I'm not going with this anymore
like if people can't take jokes that's
on them and you're oh I had a I had a
mute people I am you did the the thread
and then they started actually tagging
me cuz I guess they noticed that I muted
and I was like look like at the other
day played this game if you want cuz I
look he said anyone that likes
but you know what it is but you know
maybe you do need some mental help too
the comments on Twitter there's gotta be
something wrong with these people right
now I could just make like right now I'm
thinking down some like well uh there's
some stranger things man you know they
drinkin a that that bug juice or
something like that I'm thinking about
he's like if you could understand this
story you might need to be the stroke
jacket what Kojima and the part that
blows my mind it was a joke and then it
got to the point where it was like this
this isn't even at like people first off
a wellness check I'm not checking on you
okay but needless to say addict you were
not impressed with the Tokyo Game Show
what is it forty nine minutes or
whatever it was footage that was shown
that's your overall and you want to
bring this to the table I'm assuming
about what everyone else felt about I
I'd rather get what is that severe thing
that the army does like the
waterboarding thing oh my god before
around the route of cult I'm very
curious first of all one did you see the
dead stranding on footage from TGS and
if you did what would your impressions
know I only saw small excerpts on social
media now now I've some people got
really mad at me because I've kind of
stood up for this game right around III
they put out a trailer that moved me
pretty well like I thought oh man I I
wish Xbox had something with this much
production value this much
and this much it just had a lot of
weight to it and I know the game is
weird I know it's strange I know Kojima
how he is and he did it he doesn't make
games that I like but I know that he's
like he wants to be like the best
director ever in video games so I told a
lot of people like Xbox has never made
something like this big you know and we
need something that big but you know
something a little more grounded shadow
response so yeah so um my stance is this
game will probably get game of the year
not because of Jeff Keeley not the King
because that that's not how it works you
know it's that it is it is voted in by
the industry they all put in the votes I
know the industry loves Kojima's work
not everybody understands what he does
so I've tried to tell people just don't
blindly hate on this game because it's
Kojima and you think it's weird and it's
not for you not blindly hating on this
game we've seen stuff for three years on
this game that's that's where I'm that's
what I'm talking about like like attics
right I'm starting to evolve like I'm
seeing this weird stuff I'm like mm-hmm
really like come on shout out to you for
showing us ups man throwing piss and goo
do it spooky enemies and shout out to
the camera man that was showing Norman
Rios his crotch so I saw this I saw this
thing and like this is like Kojima style
stuff you know it's my first impression
I bought a ps3 late in the generation
yeah and I bought Metal Gear Solid 4
because it was the rave game of the
whole generation I got a couple hours in
the game and there's a soldier hiding in
an oil barrel with diarrhea and I'm like
what the crap is with Hideo Kojima I'm
like I don't understand what this
straitjacket like right people don't
like this sort of thing like why is the
guys like moaning and groaning and
and anyway I'm like I tried to play that
game it just got too weird I tried I
played like 40 hours in Metal Gear Solid
5 it wasn't going anywhere I just didn't
understand all the weirdness they when
it got really weird into the cutscenes
like 30 40 hours and I was like I can't
do this anyway rate cult they got it got
weird okay it started super weird and
then and then you're just running around
the desert sniping people for like 20 30
hours and 10 min and then you get a
story cutscene and people were infected
with this ghost alien virus and and
you're helping these little African
slave children out of a village well I
don't understand what's going on I mean
you were in Africa right I just I miss
I'm a certain game that's why I kind of
told you my story like there's certain
type of game that I just gravitate
toward and I gave Metal Gear Solid 5 in
Kojima like the most honest shot I could
and I just I just I just don't all that
sort of thing but lately with like you
can reset in the game and I don't know
if this is confirmed but I'm just gonna
repeat it as I heard it like everyone
else does and yeah that you can craft
grenades from your balls
I don't know I don't know all truth here
I read that you can craft with your body
bottle of fluids and and and and the
thing is is they showed a scene where he
goes into the toilet and area and all of
a sudden he starts crafting these
grenades we don't see how it comes out
some pee and poo bombs going in there
maybe something else we don't want to
talk about that but you know some
craziness wow that's that's pretty
attachment I mean look I didn't know
about this I just you guys judgment I
missed that one but um Falls let's get
right into it but me you've been a go
has some interesting conversations in
there
in reference to the showings so okay
you're very vocal so let's get to it
okay so I have a long history with
calling Kojima overrated okay um I do
believe he's one of the most overrated
developers there is I don't care what
anybody says my personal opinion here
the man has just made weird game after
weird game now I liked his games way
back in the day I'm going back to the
NES with a metal gear you know I liked
that game back in the day okay for what
it was it was great but when he started
to introduce these cinematics and stuff
yes he brought that to the table but at
the same time he brought that weirdness
with him too like he started smoking
something funny and when you started
bringing this stuff over I'm thinking to
myself okay I can't follow along with
your games anymore like the middle Gear
Solid franchise just went to this into
this direction where I could no longer
understand it like Colt said Metal Gear
5 you know it I played it to for about
48 hours and I didn't know what I was
playing and I'm not like that see with a
game especially a single-player
narrative game I have to have a good
narrative that is the key I have to
understand what is going on and I do not
understand what's going on in most of
his games neither do most of his fans
let's be real they try to tell me
kognito when you're just not smart you
don't get it I say I say this I say
explain Metal Gear 5 to me and then keep
none of them can explain it to me there
is so much going on in that game that
makes no sense and nobody could ever
explain if I let go GB himself if I have
one more person tell me I'm not
enlightened enough I'm gonna go clean
and strangle this person the other night
so so like I've been following this debt
that stranding series and and I call it
said they put out a couple of great
production value trailers that you're
like wow this this looks intense this
looks dramatic maybe it might be good
right and then they give us the gameplay
that little short bit of gameplay that
we thought originally and you know that
whoever did that hole Benny Hill theme -
it was hilarious if the minute trailer
comes out the other night and I'm at
work so I say you know what I got here
I'm gonna watch this whole thing I'm at
work I got yes I sit there I'm watching
this you know 50 minute you know mess of
a game flick I don't know what it is
what's going on and this dude is just
walking and walking and walking and then
all of a sudden a little fight happens
I'm like okay here we go
it's it lasts like three seconds he
chokes to do down and that's hit and go
ok more walking that I've been on easy
easy mode and you thing though then then
you get this little boss mode and then
all the Sun you know some craziness is
happening and I'm thinking oh my scum ok
while the man might be on something here
this still looks pretty cool
but the he's throwing pooh-bahs pea
bombs and stuff at him now that we know
what it what it is because at the time
we didn't know what he was but he was
throwing stuff at him I thought he was
throwing packages I didn't know I was
like hey no he's got a ton of packages
so you know later we find out it's poo
bombs and all of a sudden like this
other character pops up but he's kind of
you know almost translucent and we find
out that that's another player you can
actually call in like Souls type ya know
layering and that one's throwing poo
bombs at hand to throw back at the
creature Stefan I'm thinking okay you
know what is really the innovation here
that people speak up because this type
of game playing souls where you can call
other people and that's not really
innovative it's the are we talking the
craziness is that the innovation here
because I do crazy very well I'm telling
you right now this game is gonna get
game of the year and and for only the
next reason because the Kojima factor
okay because I'm journalist and and and
fans out there so high up on pedestal
but this games game of the year no
matter what no matter what to put out
that would be that would be something I
mean we do we all know Geoff Keighley
the game is a huge kijima fan we know
the history that would be something
let's get it right to the king man I got
a kick did you get a chance to watch
this yeah yes alright first um I wanna
attack the the part where we don't have
games of that cinematic value quantum
break actually does quantum break did a
fantastic job had the whole game come
together under a different regime had
Phil had control of it I think the game
would have been way better
they split it they was going in two
different direction as a company now def
stranden I get it shout out the lady
panda um she's a huge Kadima fan right
now you have to understand these a lot
of his fans are super fans right and
they believe they understand what the
laalili laalili really believe they
understand when he saw talking about
deep state and they really think they
understand all the dynamics they're
going to the character psyche when
they're talking about snake and the
clones and stuff like that look but it's
just like fond say you asked them it's
like you're explaining game to me can't
they can't explain it to you just
because you confused with the game's
direction does it make it great just
because you confuse with the ideology of
Kojima doesn't make it art bro um you
have to understand if you throw enough
poo at the screen something to stick and
he's actually literally making poo bombs
now you guys as a champion is new who's
telling you literally go to the bathroom
make any stranger in TV bombs and this
is a good idea
listen listen he has to be trolling you
but what I say is this somebody also put
in there that he is super smart the
level of anticipation and can
fusion about this one title it's so high
no one knows what it is and the fact
that you must play this game to figure
out why are you making pool bombs why is
a baby in your throat why the fact that
he put a baby in the throat and you're
not appalled did you see that one you
know I'm sure you did David cuz you
watch something like I didn't was bored
to tears but when you want to recharge
you sit in a puddle a dirty puddle and
you're sitting there and with your
clothes off and all of a sudden you sit
your baby in there and he's in that
little thing and the baby starts
swimming around a little dirty puddle
and you like this little clip where you
know now if you stare at Norman Reedus
his crotch you get punched I'm like well
he swell because I'm not gonna watch a
game with that not more than once
you know that it's they trying like he's
doing Japanese humor with Western styles
yes
he's merging too right and for some of
us it's really coming off terribly weird
we're not steeped inside these Japanese
games or these Japanese movies and stuff
like that their their level of funny is
different everybody's funny is their
level of humor or something that makes
it altogether
you know good the fact that he's merging
both continents both worlds together and
bringing it across he's doing a
fantastic job I'm not taking away
anything from anybody that wants to play
the game there was yeah I want to play
the game to figure out what the hell is
going on and I've been trying to figure
out what still Alalu
both paper I figure that out man you're
not gonna figure through that out here's
the thing he's making poo bombs real
quick super to supercharge on TV to
beauty tool our sous chef Kojima is the
Kanye of video caves a shot of the
digital Cagiva wants to be Christopher
Nolan so badly wants to be Christopher
Nolan let me jump it yeah gotta be
challenged for me this is this is funny
look um
when the game was announced I was just
like Cole I was like yo cinematic value
you know send my production guys looks
really good
I'm like man you know I'm saying like it
had a dark feel to it right and I was
just like I'm digging this you know this
alternate reality things still don't
know exactly what's going on but I was
like it just it was wacky enough that
but just still enough in containment
that I was like all right I'm still with
it right then I can't fry y'all like
after the Tokyo Game Show showing shot
the mods gaming man he had a good
tweakers my feelings were exactly like
to meet our demo ain't with no famous
road like I just it just felt empty it
just you know when I saw the core
gameplay loop which is basically you
have to get from one side of the earth
to the other side of the earth and you
know you got these spurts that you
interact with and then you know there's
some pseudo social element when other
people can leave their ladders around
and all this other stuff it's just look
uninspiring to me or cognate don't want
you repeat that last statement about
people leaving their ladders in the
pseudo social dig and the open world
anyone else in this entire industry made
a social event where people could leave
their ladders for other people that
would be laughed out of the room it's
just you know what it is to it it's like
okay I know people with teasing about
like whole it's a FedEx
but like literally you got the packages
on your back and it's it affects his
balance in his way so I'm like you're
literally transporting things across the
world and it's just that gameplay loop
it wasn't for me brah just did you know
Cognito that you
balance those back which you're walking
you have to like control your character
a certain way so you know and and put
the package other packages on the
certain way so you don't follow that's
just not a good mechanic to me landscape
and and this is like not just trashing
on the game to trash and make jokes but
looking at that landscape it's boring
there's nothing going on it you know
more positive I'm which if for me
uninspiring you know I'm saying like I
it just nothing moved me about it you
know saying and then the other thing I'm
gonna tell you what really pissed me off
y'all let me tell this is the part that
got me attic this is where I'm with you
kijima makes the statement and he's like
yo for my real fans don't watch what I'm
about to show you are you gonna make a
statement before tokyo game show and be
like look for all y'all you know will
they don't watch this this is not for
the hardcore you don't say cuz there's
some people that really don't know what
the game is and this is for them but i'm
like why don't you want your base to
know what this is it just it's just very
strange to me to come out with a stable
were you about to do it what is it a 40
was it was it 90 minutes how long was
that president it was it was pretty long
he's worried some of these yo what is
this it's like it almost felt like a
hustle like you I'm about to go on stage
and showcase it's for the world but I
don't want you to go beat this cuz my
hardcore duels you keep like nah fam I'm
that with that point people who is far
but is less as possible to interact with
my work cuz maybe one time they're gonna
be like yeah this time man I'm all for
originality
I'm all for uniqueness you know I'm for
a consumer being in a stranger and
Fonzie you know we sorta at the comments
we saw you know some of the things
people saying and the only get it they
understand it's not those comments to
get me it's the ones that say I don't
care what
about I don't even really care ever
understand it it's game of the year
that's what members of his base right
now let's go around I guess its last
word I get I'll get right back to you
Anna get ready
it's like king you're like yeah I've
been saying hashtag Konami was right for
a while now it went on with the
situation was he came into this and he
said check this out this is what I'm
gonna do with the next game I'm gonna
make cool bombs and P bombs and then
he's like get him out of here you know
they want to bow him I don't think they
should have like cuz like apparently
they were like forcing him to stay at
work I think I've said from the start
when this game had a couple trailers
down I was like look let's be realistic
here Konami might have been keeping this
dude in the realm of reality wanna meet
with my girlfriend again we don't know
the situation really I'm not trying to
go too crazy with it it's just he said I
know you're going in all I'm saying it
just seems the way his thought process
is he goes for it he goes all the way
out and if you're putting budget and
stuff behind him I couldn't understand
to an extent how a big publisher might
say yo fam what's going on here you
don't saying I came about you could
throw bombs alright could you mean
what's the game about though nah he's
gonna say oh what's the game about oh
well you're a FedEx delivery guy you
know and you gotta walk across the
United States delivering packages and
they're gonna be like yeah get him out
get him out now at the end of the whole
game was gonna be it was just a dream he
goes coast to coast check against the
United States creating new strains the
link dividing people people mad at you
when you
more than though I'm sorry he's an
Internet repairmen is BiBi or bridge
baby a little fetus and an artificial
honestly the people talk about
innovation and stuff and this is not
innovation craziest innovation paying on
mushrooms is not innovation is not
innovation it's a beer extreme he was
right to get rid of him you know the
thing that annoys me the most is you
know Laura Carney doll get on to me
about the medicated thing is I know this
game gonna get like an idea Metacritic I
know all these people are gonna come out
of the woodwork and say this game is but
yeah and it's just like you know a
company like you're Rob Ferguson in the
coalition really put their heart into
this game and you have people giving
this game six out of ten but these same
people are gonna sit there safe
death trainings amazing and get this
game at eight - nine - ten out of ten
there's no net foot for the sake that
was a cure for this like the fact that
he's he's doing something different that
uh is it's it's a unique thing I can
throw a rock down on that I could throw
a rock down a hallway for ten years and
start throwing kicks down the hallway
I'm changing things I'm doing even walk
into the office it threw a ball and you
know you try to stay shut you try you
try not to talk about it cuz you know
you got their case so cuz it was bad as
as this game's a PlayStation exclusive
oh you have you have the PlayStation
zealots coming at you and then they're
not even the worst part about it what's
the Kojima city comes out they're like
yo get this man he's talking about
Kojima
one thing we have they may like and King
said it you know he's got a rabid bass
he's got I mean whoever you know
whatever he puts out I mean they ride
for him man so he's gonna be Richard III
will I must admit Colt like I'm very
interested to see game like when was it
video game awards the game was when it
comes out and busy its placement and to
see what's going on and granted and look
if it comes out and there's things I
didn't see you know I'll be the first to
give it up you know but for right now
that Tokyo Game Show my interest went
down the window I was not I just wasn't
there and I was funny I was which you
cause like I was championing it the
initial trail is the the del Toro joint
I'm like okay it looks cool we're not
saying but the gameplay loop in that
empty barren world and then running side
by side like Terminator 2 next to a
truck and drably do it out and I wasn't
real quick I just want to say to attic
though attic here's the here's the
difference between you and I in this
situation um I don't like the game
I think Kojima's overrated however I
don't attack Kojima's fans
I don't you told them they need a
straightjacket or needle offer I'm about
that all the media that's why they came
after you the way they did
I still get hate for saying Kojima's
overrated but I don't beat the fair and
they go okay cuz father did he wonders
why people are attacking if people
attack me I know exactly why people were
attacking me
you know where you know I'm crazy you
know breeds crazy and I mean you know
sometimes people really like this kind
of stuff
you think the people do like his stuff
and they really respect the guy look I
respect that I can't I can't disrespect
people's taste in gaming I can't because
I have games people come down hard on me
for Red Dead all the time all the time I
get that you know it is well deserved
[Music]
better than boxing you know what there's
a difference okay
you like that trash Red Dead you know
that's wrong no it's not for me right I
knew bombs and Red Dead all right you
know what and if any game that you
should have been throwing pool balls
back then you should have been thrown
pool bombs but they weren't and we know
exactly what the game was we are so
upset and confused by it's being
confused and I think he's doing it on
purpose he doesn't want you to know
exactly what's going on before the game
comes out because you won't buy it I
think part of his allure is you not
knowing what the hell is going on and by
the time you figure it out you don't put
forty hours in it you can't get your
money back
so I understand what's going on with
this man and he's a genius I can't
[ __ ] I did not like him saying like
my hardcore fans don't watch this 45 to
90 minute presentation I'm about to do
that's gonna tell you about the game
don't like that is weird messaging to me
is weird what he was telling people it's
not a it's not an action game it's a
straight game and he kept telling people
it's a strand game it's a new genre
it's called strength and I'm like he's
making it done like time you explained
it I just got more dumber is the
stranding because you stranded in the
desert with a baby you thought you
stranded in that the baby in your throat
and you're out $60
because he took your last 60
this is a trap I'm gonna stop the hate
train here right you guys are getting
really rude on my man Coachella no no
I'm just kidding uh I think about it
this way guys you can get it to do cool
as Hideo Kojima ever put out a low-rated
game or a game that flopped but you know
what I can't say though has Kojima ever
did not did not do a concentration camp
to do reviews though because we all know
how that review for Gears 5 they made
you one right which one you talk about
yeah they they literally flew people out
to their headquarters and made them
review it there
that was him no I don't remember was his
game that was the game that they were
talking about
so he's never put out a bad game he
pioneered cinematics and movie style
production in gaming now um ok right I
left out I left out like a portion
there's a few months when in the late
late 90s when I would play playstation 1
with my brother-in-law on Sunday night
had to go over and hang out he's he was
like 13 14 years old and and he bought a
Playstation and I said dude you got to
get this Metal Gear game vice playing on
Nintendo because it was like the first
game where you actually collected things
and and you had to sneak like there's no
sneaking video game South baby
so Metal Gear Solid on the PlayStation 1
was an amazing game the storytelling was
really great
but it had some weird wacko stuff that
way back in the 90s I just kind of
rolled with you know like mantis with
the gas mask loading and all this stuff
really great game yeah I don't know what
was going on half the time but here's
the thing des [ __ ] is chocked full of
quality to use visuals are beautiful
it's gonna have a bunch of immersion
it may not be somebody said it the Chad
thing is Aiden said he makes really well
I'm gonna paraphrase he makes really
well-made games they're just not for me
and I think a lot of us feel that way
and then when King David said he tries
to meld
styles of the Japan way to wagon culture
you know yes I've known that for a long
time I mean you know I've always tried
to put my finger on that he takes like
the Japanese style action and tries to
make what he thinks is American action
movies and it doesn't it doesn't
resonate with a lot of people that live
in the states they don't it's like this
it comes off weird yes and and it's it's
not right to say weird because Japanese
culture is totally different from ours
it's not I know it's not Fon Stefan's
and I have a certain style of thing that
we like and so I that's what I say like
we kind of blind hate on this thing I
know he's gonna do really well Cole I'm
not sure if it's something that I'm
gonna love the problem that is saying
you know it's saying that you can't say
it's weird it is just wrong I mean
because poo bombs and things like that
is weird I mean every level you can
think of that's just weird dude but
here's the thing I've always given him
credit for the cinematics and everything
he was overrated because of his games
and and you bring up immersion I don't
feel like I can get a Mersenne in this
world and most people can't because they
can't understand it to me that goes
along with the immersion of a game you
have to understand what's going on let
me get this to me check one into game
stopped and asked about des training
they said they don't know what it's
about but it's kijima so I should buy it
I really want to know who is going to
buy this well and well I know it's
winning awards look I hear what both you
guys you know what JD you're on that
here's the thing we're both colt is
making a good point
in the fact that the merging of these
two type of cultures and the two type of
thought process with the games and then
obviously we're finalists and see where
I stood at is like I was with him the
Metal Gear Solid I think the one what
was the one I think was PlayStation 2
where it started off on a ship right it
was the death yeah that one I was really
into I felt the graphical fidelity was
fantastic it was the first time he was
able to hide bodies and I and he was
doing a lot of innovative things
gameplay wise right then what happened
is as we started to going you go to Big
Shell you go to these other places
is the narrative started to get too out
there for me and I think that's where
I'm on the Fonz camp where it's like
it's just this fake deepness they like
it is narrative stuff that is trying to
don't like fake neatness it's just one
of your things in the game and you like
who could it be
I called sovereign I literally picked up
my phone and said no and I called
sovereign and said what did he just do
to my game the game was so fine and it
just started to get over the top yes the
narrative and again you know for people
who understand it more power to you you
know I'm saying I'm not I'm not that
woke yet it's like I said if you want to
play this game
i'ma buy i'ma buy it if you want to you
know it is what it is but do not come at
me for saying you crazy for wanna buy
now look he can play this game but I'm
Mike look you're lucky I can't let you
do this I'm worried about your Mentos
and its status listen if I fall into the
rabbit hole and I wake up and I woke
after I played his game after the dough
baby stuff first of all let me let me
tell you when he put a baby in the
throat
I said I'm behind the game on my head
loke look he was walking around with a
little baby oh baby baby swirling around
in a little mixture right so listen
listen just like funds watched in horror
as you put the baby inside the pool of
dirty water and a baby like I said yo
for the baby factor alone I'm going to
purchase this game and you know what I
wanna see how far off the deep end this
dukkha really go because his rails is
off there's nobody guiding him and
more is like you let grandma go also
maids and grandmas loose I've come about
all that grandma's gonna bring I'm about
all of this I just can't wait to come
back and talk to you guys do you
remember back today they used to have
this thing called Tamagotchis yes yes
okay the baby's like a tamagotchi in the
game because you have to make sure the
baby's good is having its level
everything and and and that's another
aspect about the game toons so that's
another mechanic you have to deal with
and it's one again like I said with all
the other stuff I just don't want to
deal with but yet Fonz and I were
happily braiding our horses hair and
there's no shame in that because at
least I understood with that horse with
Sistina to tell me fons you didn't have
to go to your local storm you know make
some crack or something so you can
understand the story what's going on you
didn't need to get under the influence
to understand the logic that's being
played i kjd gave a final check I'm not
paying $60 to throw pool balls and PE on
things if I could might try if it ever
goes to game pass it's a game a stye
game as far as I'm concerned so to
delilah HD finally he said there's a
game pass type game that's a slap in the
face to game ball you know disrespect
funds I say this right and the reason
why I can I can see his train of thought
with that because I think he's onto
something with that right the fact that
it goes inside game past anybody that's
sitting on the gate that doesn't have
the $60.00 that want to understand
what's going on inside game past that
allows you to take the game digest the
game without the fear of loss so I can
see if it would go in there I think it
will get a whole lot more views I think
a lot of games should be in game pass
but again he has to purchase they have
to purchase that game and put it in it
if they spend 19 million on devil may
cry and
no to put this game aside some game pass
it will cost a boatload more than 19
million the last comment on a destron
will have something for everyone
stealth the sandbox fetch delivery etc I
hope the story comes together we do too
because I don't understand
moving along man Borderlands 3 is out
here man out of the street it has
released this week and I just want to
break this down from our three
perspectives one would be there's a lot
going on in reference to the review code
situation I mean not a lot of outlets
did get it and want to talk about that
and then you know as far as kind of how
gearbox is handling it and then the
other thing is obviously you know we did
hear some armed technical issues I want
a shout out you boy the leader of the
RDX a dealer gave me made some comments
and reference to it you know far as
frame pacing frame rate all that good
stuff you know I want to talk about that
and then the third part will be about
the gameplay so let's start back with
more cold one I know you've been playing
it you know I'm saying so we'll get into
that but I want to start first with do
you were you aware of like the review
cold situation well about what was going
on and not a lot of people getting their
hands on it
yeah dealers I don't know if you said
this but he was supposed to get he
probably has them doesn't I don't know
he was supposed to get the review code
and he didn't okay um some of the people
community or like hey I've been asking
gearbox over and over one of my friends
is a content creator I was like I've
been asking over and over for this and I
didn't get a code and I said hey I've
message in last time like drew nobody
got a code nobody got a code for this I
don't know there's kind of some weird
stuff with gearbox now Gears 5 that went
through a lot of problems a week after a
review people got it and the coalition
and Xbox were all over social media
saying we hear you we're working on it
we're doing this this is the problem
this is on the server these are being
patched your progression is saved your
progression is coming forward when all
the Pats come through there hasn't been
a single word from gearbox or from
Borderlands social media saying anything
about performance issues they haven't
spoken up they have
and acknowledged it they're not fixing
it that needs to be taken care of now I
have also that any performance issues oh
did you yeah in fact I thought that the
I thought the game was running a lot
worse the digital foundry just explained
yesterday in their video I told dealer
and ran that I felt like the game was
running at 60 and then when combat would
pop off it would drop to like 30 and
just hold there I never ever never had a
problem controlling the game you know
how you see these frame time graphs on
digital foundry and you see like this
the waves and the spikes going up and
down I felt like it was trying to hold
60 and then when you get into combat it
would drop down and that line would stay
really steady but actually it's coming
down halfway between 30 and 60 like 47
or 50 my voice is so shot from being
sick this week but no it's not great
don't worry but uh but yeah this is a
problem the other thing that's really
crazy that we should get into in a
minute or now is that gearbox didn't
even give the Xbox one exits do it's
running the same resolution as a pro the
graphics power is 25 to 30% more on the
ex and the pro there is no texture
filtering which is built into the Xbox
one X so what it looks like and I never
point fingers on my channel I just try
and tell it how I see it and how I see
it is that the gearbox developers said
PlayStation is the biggest platform
throw all your time at that and then we
know the X is capable just make sure it
rents well let me back out the Xbox one
X is capable let's make sure it runs
well on there okay and they should have
given it its due because there may be as
many Xbox when X is out there as there
are pros there could be right I don't
know but there and that's not a small
number right definitely here we go with
that I definitely tested on X in one of
the things that surprised me was
obviously we have that option to pick
between you know performance and
resolution
so I I looked at both yeah like it was
kind of the same thing you said I'll
cold like I I got that same Bob so the
enemy start to get on it I started
seeing really strong tips and then um as
far as the frame pacing it felt a bit
off and I was a little surprised but a
little surprised but graphically it
wasn't that amazing to me now back to
the review code thing I know you said
referencing dealer stuff like that
do you feel it is strange if a dev you
know limits the review copies in them in
the fashion that gearbox is doing you
know cuz I've seen both sides of it some
people say yo this is shady you know how
come they could you know they're not
giving it everybody or anybody who
talked negative about it they're not
giving it to and then I've heard other
people that say no this is not too out
of the norm shot to Paul to ask a couple
other people you know because they were
say apparently like they their review
code was like you have to log into like
a almost like I don't say like a debug
type build but you have to log into epic
to get you know a different type of
access was their version of the review
cold so cold do you feel where do you
stand on that side as far as the way
gearbox is handling the dissemination
this is not normal it's not normal for
review codes to go out just to North
America or the United States Windows
Central didn't get one a whole bunch of
people didn't get a code um I think
digital foundry didn't even and I
analyzed this till this weekend when
they had the game in hand so let me just
get dropped my shady theory and then
I'll back off the microsecond gearbox
was worried about the PR it was
speculated that they didn't give review
coats to influencers that didn't
glowingly praised the game now this is
another problem going forward I think
publishers are afraid of influencers as
some of these big youtubers there's like
big ones like skill up and other was a
really well respective of their stuff
yeah these big influencers they have
more reach than some of these publishers
marketing teams so they and I think
they're intimidated by that and I don't
mean that super negative um influencers
are a big deal people listen that's why
I say that reviews are just one tool
go to your favorite youtuber go to your
favorite friend and go to a review site
and then sprinkling a little bit of
Metacritic in there and then figure out
we want to pay 60 bucks day one so
gearbox did something here where they
cherry picked where they're gonna send
the game codes out because I think
they're afraid that they're gonna get
bombed yeah by the because people hive
mind
yeah and they and they they've gathered
together and they fear monger and
negativity cells it's a horrible
situation I don't I don't endorse either
side the way that social media and
gamers the social media act and how
these publishers reaction right now we
need to have a happy medium situation
and then also did you get a chance to
play it did you get a chance to
experience it no not a big fan of the
game myself of the series I should say
but I do agree with Colt that you know
living in a time of that tribal culture
everybody seems to just gravitate to
those people around them that they feel
comfortable with or or they look up to
sometimes and then they just sort of
take on their narrative and mm-hmm
then they run with it I mean we've see
that all the time I mean I mean you can
say that you know even quote might have
followers to just you know wolves spew
whatever he's saying good or bad you
know in in the codes is on the money
most of the times I really enjoy pios
but I'm just saying that there is people
out there that do this and this just
culture we live in and it kind of sucks
but I will say that you know I know
people are having a lot of fun with it
and that's great you know but I don't
really have the review code situation by
gearbox is spooky and obviously you
played it I know maybe you've talked so
I want you to be in on that too I mean
the review code thing that's not really
normal
I don't know what that's about I think
you know it's a combination
they rushed the game out because
apparently you know we forget about
battleborn
who knows what kind of damage I did to
the company so they probably needed a W
and probably the is their company public
I don't know if if gearbox is a public
company yes so you know their investors
probably wanted to see results so you
know they do whatever publisher does
let's do some slimy stuff to get this
product now let's do this gearbox stuff
unless cherry-pick people we've probably
already talked to we have an
understanding where this is going
we're gonna try to get as much sales as
possible to these I'm sure epic gave
them all types of money too and then you
know we're gonna rock and then we're
gonna fix it later after we all rock it
and then we're gonna fix it after it's
already out and I'm tired of this media
company the states with the file I see
which had the game feels rushed and it
does have lots of issues put this game
or game pass save your money
every time I played this game like they
you know the performance it hurts the
you know the the atmosphere of playing
it like you know I feel like really cuz
I have about I think three or four hours
into it mmm-hmm I played it for a couple
hours the first night it came out and
it's it's not that level of polish it I
think it what made it worse isn't I just
played Gears five so like my song polish
I saw a game like you know I had a lot
of issues with gears five right but at
least I felt like I was playing the game
like this it just feels like you know oh
you know this is cool
I killed the same I killed the same site
uh
psycho fifteen times oh there's some
strides I killed that like it felt like
it was missing that like that world
reaction like and you know that's just
always been that's always been
Borderlands and that's not necessarily
making a bad thing you know I love the
guns I like what they did with the guns
I like a lot of the you know the small
thing they did with
you know the animations and how the
stores look down right like it low-key
felt like a Borderlands 2.5 attic bring
it is great point though attic when you
talk about how you know they brought
this game out and it's bugging you they
probably should have had more time here
I mean that goes for a lot of games
nowadays and I think that's that's the
the biggest issue here is those
publishers they they put those demands
you know that Street date and they want
the game out by then and I understand
that but sometimes I think these
publishers need to understand that you
gotta let the developers work yeah and
and I think that's the main issue
because what happens what happens when a
game like this comes out do they attack
the publisher no they go straight after
the developers on Twitter or whatever
and and it's their fault you know and
ultimately yes it is but at the same
time like those those dates sometimes it
is their fault but Rita you're being
like you can't make a 20 minute pizza in
ten minutes
yeah and I think I love the fact that we
have companies like CD Projekt RED and
now Bungie they're out on their own and
put themselves they said go back no
because we're not going to be ready by
then and I applaud that and you know the
reason they they even said the reason
they're able to do that is because they
don't have Activision breathing down
they breath where's that money kid
borderlines is five or less three so now
I would reckon you know what I was gonna
review this game yeah I'm about to just
make that 10-minute video why I dropped
Borderlands 3 hello like you you you can
I do not write if you like Borderlands
you're gonna love these this Borderlands
I enjoy it it's fun but I don't think
it's worth 60 like I love you know like
especially the performance issues
they're having you know I had people
attacking me on Twitter you playing it
I'm yes look I didn't tell what you
complained it on the X that doesn't look
much better and you know a lot of the
things that going on will coat - you
know coats right it probably doesn't
have any special time I don't
necessarily think that's because of the
the PlayStation install base I just
think that's all about a time crunch you
know that they might tell us they had
three years but all since they had 22.5
there's a difference between a game that
you say addicts not worth 60 you trying
too hard I mean I guess man I guess
you're trying too hard just say it's
worth 60 I'm not I literally flipped
that whole statement around on you slow
King man did you pick it up no I didn't
pick it up no it's not that it's not the
fact that uh you know I don't like the
game I do want to try the game I saw how
hard the CEO was pushing for his team
with the game and I do feel like there's
an internal struggle and I do feel that
he champions his team now um I don't
know if they gave as much attention to
the Xbox version as they gave the
PlayStation version install bases do
carry a large factor guys all right so
the fact that it's well-known that the
PlayStation has over a hundred million
units out there of course you will cater
to that all right I mean it's just only
common sense and there's only business
knowledge now of course we wanted fair
an equal across the boards we also know
that one machine is more powerful than
other machine I don't care how you want
to slice it that's a fact but if it's
running poorly on a more powerful
machine it can only allow you to deduce
the fact that it wasn't put as the lead
platform and it wasn't utilized to its
ultimate capabilities all right so again
it would you be upset yes you should be
upset if you purchase an ax and you
expected to have superior performance
over the other versions of the game I
would be pissed off
now as far as you giving our review
codes and your freight this is the
culture that we live in now guys this is
the culture that we are manifesting and
we are pushing forward we have companies
saying that they are afraid of negative
reactions companies should not be afraid
of negative reactions companies should
be welcoming what's wrong with our game
how can we make it better but it got to
the point now that any negative review
any negative thing gets a tribal
mentality going forward and it starts to
push this stuff down you start to push
Metacritic scores down you start to make
people walk away from a game that
doesn't get life and it needs life at
the same time
you cannot put out a game that's not
ready yet so we understand that the
boardroom controls exactly what's going
on with a company the company might say
that you listen we need at least four
more weeks because the frame pacing is
not as good and we need to get this to
go we need this right and if they tell
you know we got quarterly things and we
I gotta go on vacation and I pay for
this so you got to make sure that this
game gets out so I can get my residuals
listen and they say stupid stuff like
technology is really good and technology
is really bad where they can put a game
on where patch it later
that patch it later mentality is gonna
hurt our own community because you can't
keep putting out buggy games and then
getting two weeks later a five megabit
download took fix a game that should
have been fixed initially so you know
it's you know it's suck really bad and
this isn't an excuse for them but
imagine being on crunch a little bit of
overtime that last like month before the
game launches or you know like we're
getting ready and then they like decide
like it's good advice to say hey we need
one more month make sure it runs fine
but like they're already in finalization
getting ready to finish the game they're
working their butts off and then the
boss has to come and say hey we need to
do this for another month and then
launch they they want that seems like
they're avoiding that but it's so
important because video gaming is a huge
business it's I think it's starting to
surpass movies almost like how much it
makes it's so worth it and at when's the
last time we heard about a game being
delayed it seems like it's been a while
what's the last one you guys heard that
got delayed we need more polish time
crack now Furies
well crackdown don't care government
status right I mean literally
everybody's laughing at the fact that
crackdown 3 was delayed and I applaud
Phil when he when they when he did it ok
because it was a step in the right
direction for the company I'm gonna
champion that position for this when I
played that game in this initial state
if he would have dropped that game
literally it would have been worth the
scores that everybody put up for it now
there's the finished product that I got
afterward I was thoroughly impressed
with the finished product because having
seen the previous product so to give it
that time but not every company has that
ability to say you know um let's push it
a month later and just like you said the
crunch if you're in crunch mode if
somebody else tells you they come in you
like god we got two more days for crunch
and then come innocent now you got 28
more days for crunch or the difference
between like some like Microsoft and
like a small cut I mean your gears that
bollocks they're probably not small
small but you know the people you know
well they're pablo that's probably even
worse like a male bad that came out
really bad 2k breathing down they back
it's like look like we need this done by
now and a lot of these executives of
stuff they're not gamers they they know
they might have some kind of mentality
of what a product will look like if it
had that time and they don't they don't
really know the difference they're like
when they just see money they're like we
want this by now our investors are being
told this is coming out now yeah and you
got a we don't know what goes on behind
closed doors it could have low keep and
push back three times
mm-hmm let me jump in real quick man
this giant um look
shout out to I guess a dealer who put
that thing out a tweet I was a great
tweet it because I was experienced the
same thing with the X version I was
surprised because I was like this is a
game in my opinion the action handle you
know no problem in the field it was that
you know graphically you know the
fidelity was that crazy you know but
that's just me but on the thing that
surprised me I want a shout out to um
actually Laura Dessler Gary for my Jenn
our good boy arm what you call it up Dan
McCullough the head of Xbox laughing we
had on the show before and they both
tweeted some scary stuff to me man about
the cloud saves and and how people were
losing progress and - from be wrong
we're having this webinar it the whole
game feels like a rush product yeah
that's the part the concern again is
that just an exclusive to the epic story
issue is that only them I mean I'm
hearing stories of people their
characters completely deleted loss
progress gotta start from the beginning
that's spooky you know saying so I got
it
she would that possibly be epic story
look at you look at you keep it forever
Claire like it's not epic it's gotta be
listen as much as we vacate before epic
we gotta call it down alive fair it's
fair it's spooky day and I remember they
just announced cloud slate saves as a
feature recently so I don't know if they
don't got this thing really you know I
opted amaizing but look so that's that
you know with far as gameplay I got a
chance to play it for a few hours or
whatever classic Borderlands
over-the-top you don't say the gun feel
good it's a fun game it's just it's
vintage Borderlands you know I'm saying
I picked scene I like the character you
don't saying a little ability stuff like
that and I think you said it best I
think it's just like it's one of those
things that if you love Borderlands
you're in good I'm saying if you never
was a Borderlands fan I don't know if
this one Wow's you to get you over the
top you know I'm saying so long you know
I got to say something about sequels
real quick because there's a double
standard we really have to be real that
sequels are more of the same that we
love yeah and I look at some of our
favorite sequels and they always add
about 25% more mm-hmm
to make the game better than the last
one and hopefully it's better than last
one but when I look at gears gears has
always been a little bit better judgment
went down I still love judgment no gears
for improved combat sped it up yours
force okay it's good it's good
here's five fire yes now I look at
uncharted I love one
I love two three is alright I'm still
great I love for like and look at
uncharted like it it does what they
added rope swinging mm-hmm like you know
it's and they added like some Jeep you
can drive around that's it the game's
fantastic that we like we hear people
bash on games for doing the same of what
a dick knows where I'm going you know
he's talking about Borderlands it's it's
a third one I felt like this is just
this is too much like Borderlands
yeah yeah it's so I mean what that's
what we want to seek what we want what
we love with a bunch of new things and I
think almost all sequels do that now
where the exception comes in on big
mainstream games is got a war in 2018
got a war changed a formula now that's
not the gold standard that was an
exception that kicked butt I got a war
they they were told no you can't do the
top down like isometric it's not
top-down isometric but you can't do this
fixed camera right hack-and-slash you
got to evolve it and they did they
knocked it out of the park not every
game and every sequel is going to be
able to reformulate a sequel
we love sequels we love a lot of these
games and you can't harp on games like
gears 5 for being more the same they did
they added a lot to make it a new sequel
they're evolving the franchise slowly
giving you what you love mmm
I'm tired of people saying it's just
another this it's just another that
mm-hmm
the franchise are they're milked for a
reason there's a million Mario games
there's a million zillion there's a
million halo gates because we love them
you know these are the same people that
play called caught every year you don't
want to change up your formula if it's
successful oh yeah I'm sorry you know
you don't go to watch a die hard movie
and you want a love drama you always
change the inside of the foundation and
not the foundation I mean you got all
you guys are right you don't saying
because again if it's not broke don't
you know no need to fix it but then
again like I said with god wars that
unique thing right where it they
literally change the actual gameplay
dynamic did something which is very
crazy we got a super shell that I want
and I want D to make dizzy did you get
to me yet let me explain he doesn't ask
for need for himself pause asking for
sovereign sovereign has a thought that
he believes that PlayStation when you
get it you're going to put in your
PlayStation 4 disc and you're gonna play
it straight up
I'm telling you that's not gonna happen
you have to swipe your credit card you
want out of your playstation 5 in order
to play any old games their eyes know
they don't have the technology but they
do have the card reader on the side that
you briefly um filled ominous enough
filled luminescent might be in trouble
King streaming Wars man the streaming
wars have started man we got EA's
project Atlas and I believe Apple arcade
so uh real quickly will do the tale of
the tape a blockade will be released
September 9th
it'll be five hours looks like a month
for one of six people who is gonna be a
mostly all you know Apple devices there
will be a controller and a hundred
exclusive games to start and then we
have EA's project atlas there are people
are now saying that they're getting
access to it because I believe there's
like a technical then I kind of came out
of nowhere
I mean I'm saying but um yeah pretty
much if you have an EA access origin
account you could sign up you get part
of this technical test you and I'm
saying so arm I think the games right
now for testing for streaming or
pfeiffer time for to meet with speed
rivals and unravel so that is the latest
entry into the streaming war so I want
to bring this to the table you know
saying start with Norco like how much of
a threat do we think both of these polls
to project X cloud in Gulu stadia so
let's start with Lord Coe each way uh I
don't know uh we haven't heard enough
about X cloud I don't even know how many
games were going to get with it other
than like a list of 25 but I do know
that X cloud has the big infrastructure
so I think X cloud will be leading the
stream you so it doesn't really matter I
think they're going to lead the way and
they're going to set to set the example
of how
streamings going to work are you saying
that from inside analogy going on at e3
called hey they got to I got to stand
there and talk to bill Stilwell for
saluted me well yeah for a little bit
like um he was like I know who you are
cool oh no I'm yeah like he was like an
old friend it was really cool he was
really awesome yeah they're really
excited
they look really confident did you guys
notice that when you were there d3
absolutely man we touched it and what we
were playing it like I said again
they're what control conditions but it
was Wireless and the datacenter was
about 400 miles away and I'm gonna tell
you right now I did I played halo 5 I
didn't have any discernable egg I was
very impressed so yeah we what we all
all of us here you know say for the most
part we touched it so um I guess real
quick cold though with arm EA any any
concerns with them and all making a mark
or even challenging state here in any
country yeah they're huge
but then they have really big games but
they're not they're not very well
trusted are they you know people have
like the bad taste in their mouth about
EA so what should I give them a
subscription fee per month well I give
it a try but I think people I think lots
of people are gonna try stadia lots of
people are gonna try X cloud lots of
people are gonna try EA and that's where
it's just gonna it's gonna be that thing
when everyone launches mm-hmm we're
gonna find out what who stays around
we're but I think EA does have a big
impact no doubt the Brat final super
chat Hale Kojima has never made a bad
game why are gamers worried give halo to
the coalition yes salute Brava fede have
a great day that's what so football zone
we almost there there's a lot of food
companies and that's a good idea though
it's an they poison thousands of people
[Music]
the champion of streaming special what
do you feel about the new challenges on
the scene to Google on stadia Anna X
cloud with Apple arcade at project
Cadmus
what do I
I'm like you know they're not gonna call
on me for this table I don't care who it
is
ba what whatever yeah I mean you know
fugu you got them all in there say
something nice um I think wow yes I
think they got the best shot because
they have the game to back it up they
have a library already there and and
that's the thing with these other
services that it's just not there it's
not an option for them it's just all or
nothing we got streaming or you got
nothing mm-hmm what the quality of games
there right I can't cover it all the
copy the quality games I think one game
I vaguely heard of that's on their list
yeah so but I mean I think Microsoft has
it in the bag just because of the of it
being an option period um because it's
something like this look I do typically
I would not want to stream anything
that's just not my thing I want faxer
however if I'm at work and I got that
downtime I might get but game pass Fonz
I gotta stop you because I'm so proud of
you right now the fact that you just
said they like well you were so anti
that even consider the fact that you
thought of one use for it I am proud my
heart my heart swells I mean I can I can
imagine myself maybe trying to get that
daily done or whatever just something to
do it it's not like I'm gonna go and go
a grade or anything but or or I might
fraud it and do that
no it's just one of those things where
you know I can see the appeal in certain
scenarios and that is what is appealing
about Microsoft service the fact that it
is an option but for you know stadia and
you know ei when you buy the games there
it doesn't transfer over to your
physical hardware games and that is that
is a big issue that is a problem and I
think that they need to fix that in
order to make that more appealing but
bigger Sox got in the bag we know but
what do you feel these are serious
threats coming into the scene with EA
project atlas in our apple arcade it's
like it it's like fafsa and cold they
have no foundation project stadia is the
only only streaming service that I can
see even do remotely good in this Pro in
this field yeah you know they're
building a house Microsoft and Google
already owned the whole mansion you know
what I highly doubt it
like if I were to put a percentage on
these other products doing anything I'd
give all them like a 10 to 15 and
Microsoft and Google like the majority
of it okay so the Han Solo laughing at
the mere mention if an apple arcade oh
good lord kick it here man you are
another person who touched the magic of
X cloud now we got new challenges on the
scene King we got a duck down do we got
to get low oh boy alright so um Apple
arcades gonna do fantastic an arcade is
gonna knock it out the park
Apple arcade is going to do numbers day
to make you guys jump back and say are
you serious really you know why because
there's millions of Apple phones out
there so they already have an install
base that's ready to rock on the jump
they're gonna be pushing that narrative
through your fault good let's put that
to the side
knowing that you and your little phone
device is not going anyplace other than
your little phone device all right
that's nice they're gonna do that and
that's fantastic they want to hit those
billion just like everybody else five
dollars a month is nothing to think
about
boom add that to it mom for my bill I
don't care I can get to play these games
that's great and if they
up in the turn out to be really good
games good stadia is going to be just
like slow-mo back slaps a stillborn it's
going to be anthem it's going to be
anthem just for the same reason why
Fonzarelli just said it's no physical
mmm okay when they have that first
hiccup and you can't log into something
that you paid $60 for that you can't get
your fingers on the level of frustration
is gonna shoot straight through the roof
I don't know who they're marketing this
thing - I don't know it I don't see the
market for the future
listen I told you before I didn't see
the market for anthem everybody laughed
at me I didn't see where it fit it
doesn't fit this this thing does not fit
into our ecosystem a few you know paws
is comfortable right now
you just heard funds I've never thought
I would ever hear behind is rate or
something he might be an array with me
like yo-yo King you think we can do the
section real quick listen that's huge
to make funds y'all gotta understand
this man this man was not about this not
about I can't wait for its cloud to go
out and I start kicking people from
Ray's because they all know you know
what listen that's that tells you
something that he sees something in it
right he's heard enough he's trusted
people around him has given him the
information back that he's feel
comfortable is a level of comfortability
that you have which a company right fons
has a level that he sees he said well
you know they do have the games they do
have the infrastructure it does make
sense and if it's at a rate where I can
afford it and it can fit into something
I can see me using this feature it's an
option and it's giving funds the option
it's not the sole right the sole thing
being stadium right it's another option
on Apple - you know that's the thing
it's practical you know it I can see how
some people can use it in
the way I want to use it but like stadia
they just to me that whole business
model where all your games are tied to
the Internet is just it's bad I mean
look what happened when xbox live one
down if you were game sharing you
couldn't even play games offline I feel
bad for the people on Xbox Live they're
gonna have worse connections and someone
that's on they have like Walmart
Internet some point I can't imagine you
like look man like you get on the X
cloud stop with this nonsense yo
internet Jovi right quick we gotta get
out of it but um look this was
interesting to me I gotta be honest I
got a little bit to say here um apple
arcade I'm not I see what Kim you're
going because of the install base I'm
not too worried about it I think the
thing they've actually have is a low
barrier for entry I'll give you that you
know you can download it over stadia I
give you that but I looked at those 50
games that they had and like I said I
could barely recognize anything I'm just
curious if their games are going to
appear and they they giving us all those
games on racks that no one cases but
this you know I mean no disrespect you
don't say like this a lot of Indian I've
never even heard and again we shall see
I don't want to be completely dismissive
but the thing that I'm worried about
there means that stadia has over them is
the big Triple A games you know I'm
saying you can say what you want about
stadia but they got the cyberpunks the
Destiny's the divisions they got games
in that service that are pretty big so I
got I got to give them that and then
also what Apple's infrastructure that
I'm worried about is like just to make
an app in their store the process that
you have to go through it's it's very
stringent and and I'm concerned about
Indies have already started complaining
about Store visibility how their titles
will be featured in that store and then
Apple has the notorious history of like
policies of just removing your store I
mean moving your game from the store
your app from the store without reason
so that it's very difficult yeah
actually I have a couple friends that
you know published games and stuff and
yeah there their goal was going on there
you know especially steam it's like you
know they what when they do these these
release they like open the floodgates
and it's hard for their game to get
shine cuz you have like forty different
DLCs for some what game the one play
think about just from an app perspective
you know how hard it is to get because
they have a controlled environment where
Apple gets the cut right soon that is
not necessarily the most ideal situation
for an indie developer and there are
concerns about that so they're gonna
have to uphill battle on that let's get
right to the main event though EA
alright this is interesting to me y'all
it's cold I gotta be I like this I think
this is a little sneaky Power Move you
might not agree with me but I think this
is a sneaky problem this is why let's
give credit what is he a doing last oh
yeah I didn't even address yeah yeah
because I got EA access and I'm not
happy when I just told I was gonna shut
it off okay what is da doing I have no
date all right right now the it's called
project outlet Atlas right it's
available for select users you know I'm
saying who have access to it you can
stream their games I believe fight for
um titanfall it's about four or five of
their major games that's on it right now
that you can stream it's in testing
right now this came out of nowhere like
no one even knew they were doing this
right so here's my thing
say what you want about EA at the end of
the day they was the old G king like
when it came to services I know we got a
past EA Maxis was out there in the front
line before everybody right and kind of
carry it's a game pass would be a thing
about y-axis his number one number two
fawns we gonna we gonna take it back
right now if you remember your history
x-men expand and all that but remember
EA wouldn't allow their games on xbox
live for a bit member that period we're
back in a day during like 360 air until
they worked out a deal I believe in Gulu
report them is they've been known to not
play nice with their network
infrastructure right so here's my thing
the key for me I want shout out the
brass Sam she's got a great video out
please watch it
yo they've got a huge library regardless
of how we feel about EA in some of their
games and we
Anton flop they've got the games I'm
saying or on nature you know there
here's the second thing from a technical
standpoint coal that down with Amazon
AWS so that's already one of the big
three cuz we got Google as your cloud in
Amazon those are the bigger if you want
to be kind of world wide as far as the
considered the best there on it but
here's the thing are that they doing
that's kind of kind of deep to me not
only are they
partnering with Amazon they have a
structured that they can just they
they're allowing other cloud vendors
where Amazon is not in to partner up to
put EA project atlas on it that's
different from what nobody's doing if
their partner of Amazon twitches
available to them to write so here's the
thing this is serious job because again
with Microsoft they're limited to where
a sure is act so let's just say
hypothetically Amazon is not I mean
Ezra's not in Singapore I'm just making
stuff up right now right mmm so if EA if
let's just say it is with Amazon let's
just say Amazon is not there Singapore
what a is a sense doing to say hey who's
got the cloud infrastructure out there
Singapore we're allowing and we're
working with cloud vendors to also put
project Atlas in these places in
conjunction so that's a bigger reach you
don't feel like to me that's a serious
if you want to throw something else into
the mix seek and also you know we have
to talk about things like marketing
deals because there will be games that
are gonna be held from other platforms
no button bro you stole my thought that
here's where we go
that is the party I got a rock with me
now here's the deal again we talked
about the hardball point right we spoke
to cult
we spoke to all shout the bill still
rush out to all those guys are the
project s currently from our
understanding right as far as streaming
is concerned it's literally baked into
the API all Microsoft got to do is flip
a switch boom
it could be one that's cloud right no if
EA wanna be dirty they could say all our
titles are not Project X cloud X there
are Patrick Atlas exclusive you can't
rock but they could run down or fill and
said no we got games and go do that I
would I would say the chances of that
being is extremely hot extremely high so
is my fig again people clown ei but I
looked at the last two MPD's y'all guess
what's up in there
Madden all the time you know San now
hypothetically we don't say let's just
say those are the perfect gangster plan
exact let's hypothetically let's just
say anthem was fire we know they got
titanfall Pfeiffer say what you want
about the loo boxes all that we know
what Foucauldian are no one should ever
say let's say let's just say to the new
dragons age is what it is they got those
heavy guns in the chamber yeah have gone
further we've no stadium you know he a
game
yeah it's not putting old gay anthem was
ammunition it'd be a petty yeah it's
very petty yes maybe that's just a
business movement they're making a
streaming service they need to pull
their strip their product off on the
street I don't feel shadows debris
battlefields another one that they got
undertook apex legend is undertook these
are huge games that theoretically could
not be on X cloud okay take it and go
over there let's see what happens when
you stop see when the tree falls in the
forest no one else and it landed right
okay so you jump out and threw your face
out here without telling anybody who
check it out you know you came out the
tree gonna fall in the forest and you're
gonna land in the bushes gonna happen so
that they can do whatever they want to
do people are gonna go get mad and the
same way they've been buying man and
from store so you what you wanna do is
you wanna isolate show populace this is
what's gonna happen when you if you turn
that into a force factor but you have to
get out of lay down really you wanna
listen you gonna see Phil bide them so
if they try to run down on Phil Dominus
Maximus let trust in a baby
say nothing move over here
I believe if they do that this is what's
gonna happen this is when he is right
and this is how you can gauge how it
will go anybody on this panel purchaser
you might not just me you were
forgetting a big thing hype again this
is all speculation I don't know it from
its no inside baseball but one would
have to think the same way we're
assuming project s cloud is going to be
on on what you call it's part of the you
know what the game past situation it
linked up one would have to assume EA
axis is going to be baked into project
catalyst right all I'm saying is you
know and again please shout the brass
saying is you got a tremendous video out
right now is that these guys don't like
pain royalty fees to Microsoft for Sony
because I put their games on we got it
we got to come to fill Ben Denis you'll
put our John on your service you get
your cut this would be EA taking out the
middleman
this will be EA se X still gonna have
their physical games yes K they still
gonna do it they'll be stupid to
eliminate that base of the Sony
Playstation and the Xbox you don't
equals no yeah I'm gonna get I'm gonna
get right right now I'm gonna destroy
your whole Terry right now oh you don't
need a trapdoor and I'm about to push
you in the trap bowl right now right now
you don't open up your trap door let you
finish and I'm gonna push you
but here if if the if their release
first of all when is it release because
they look like they get [ __ ] it up
just came out of nowhere and the pricing
model if they keep to what okay here's
the trapdoor Jess for you I noticed that
EA access is on what PlayStation and
Xbox yeah I noticed they didn't need a
vehicle to go forward your engagement
will be in this area sir so if it's on
EA access and it's baked then it's ready
they'll an Xbox and if Phil won't play
dirty pool and PlayStation pool we don't
want your stuff service over here so you
can just buy your games physically let
them go purchase their games are you
implying that any actions might get
robust when you go to hit your app and
it says no longer in school you know if
they want to freeze them out and starve
them listen they didn't want getting out
of lay down the knees will be better
better but this is a fun with me right
we got to get out of here is late we got
football going in rocket new il peephole
with both the latest gameplay and
information reveals of death stranding
at the Tokyo Game Show and Gamescom how
has this affected your excitement for
the release on November 8th for
PlayStation 4 the choices are a more
excited Kojima is attempting something
very cool and unique be Fed Ex baby
walking simulator road F stranding in
the bushes or C I don't care
Konami might be on to something death is
the question those are the choices
please Rock the aisle people when it
goes up later on Twitter
Lord Coe Eastwood and Fonzarelli with
this safe how could a find people find
you
not with Lord cope man wicked upon
people find you what do you have going
awesome you can find me on Twitter at
cult Eastwood you can find me on xbox
live at cold Eastwood you can find me on
Steam at Kobey's with 99 you can find me
at PSN at cold epub you can find me at
[Laughter]
Instagram Instagram I post my thumbnails
nah and sometimes screenshots I had
called Eastwood no find me first and
foremost at YouTube it cold eastwood
subscribe i am so close maybe in a
couple weeks I'll hit 70 thousand
subscribers Wow
so that's been awesome two years about
two and a half years ago I think I was
at like 1500 subscribers so it's been a
really fun ride I'm also on RDX every
Thursday night everything's usually the
only podcast
I rarely guest on other podcasts because
life's so busy but having the Lords on
RDX twice has been like eight absolute
treasure when they're on like I can't
even do the show I'm laughing I head off
the whole time so they just bring like
that energy I'm so it's been so cool to
be on here so
thank you guys I didn't really
appreciate it my thank back thank you so
much cold bad no this is long overdue we
would talk a long time it's so good to
have you in the realm and huge family at
work continued that ascension definitely
let's get him up there man they the guy
again
like I was telling phones I mean I don't
even know how you guys do it I know the
amount of work you guys put into these
videos it's tremendous man really is so
we definitely salute I almost lose to
the r-tx crew you don't stay in dealing
sock a deep badge oh cool it's like we
got to do is it to six oh you got the
tip dawg so now you have a boy yeah oh
this is litmus out to them to the
audience but of course lord Fonzarelli
the grounded gamer talking that could
she would talk all about Rome forever
we could've you know it's my pleasure
you know my pleasure to talk badly about
cookie you know come over here and get
the frog Loki's sake of my LLL try
that's what I mean though I'm happy to
get that from King David you know I got
a number love for him and all of you
guys here on the panel and I mean
honestly like it's a secondary family to
me outside of my RDX family so it's
really good so it's good to have these
two worlds collide kids in my opinion
it's a few bad podcasts out there period
but I support so anyway I just want to
say you can find me at Jay Fonzarelli on
Twitter and the grounded gamer here on
YouTube where I'm making videos Wow so
please all vehicle yeah I got another
one coming Monday and cyberpunk news
a tribe you know I'm putting more even
more effort into them now yeah not that
people really care but hey it's like all
you already X guys they're your videos
that's it sounded dealer gave a video he
I gotta get the deal of gaming on the
stimulus package everybody I like yeah I
got an all-star team oh I love the squad
man beautiful good good guys good again
really support you guys it's always good
to get something going with RDX that's
always fun yeah RDX is amazing man it's
been it's been so much fun there I mean
the last couple of years has been
arrival dealer Gaming is a it is an
amazing guy like a lot of people give
him hate but the guy is a genuine guy I
mean like he'd give you the shirt off
his back he's such a nice guy man and
people don't see that but man he care
yes look too cold for actually his
account really it touched a lot of
people to tell you they said some cool
things about dealer which is awesome so
salut again RDX in the dealer gaming
Lord addict man lied a lot a lot of
energy today so we could have five
people Pfizer
you'd find me in the middle of the
battlefield with all the Kojima fanboys
a stranger you won't know that I was
victor in this battle
it must be a game of thrones you liked
it was a battle the basses which goes by
himself about to take over the whole
boat RV sword I guess like Doctor
Strange back at them that's how you
gotta do what you got good or bad way to
find people find you can find me on
Twitter and a lord addict IOP that is
where the the battle is being took in
place you can find me on youtube and a
gaming addict definitely just posted my
crack down review not crack crack and so
next time I'm gonna tell this battle is
won see you next week already the Lord
King dropping the jewels not feeling by
EA talk today I loved it I want to say
thank you to our esteemed guests and
especially thank you to cope um you said
you fanboy doubt when dealer messaged
you right did when I saw you I fanboy
doubt I did too I mean I'm not I'm I say
I did I because we've been on the RDX
and stuff and like yeah I couldn't
believe it is it I'm gonna steal your
I'm gonna steal your chance to like try
to put me on a pedestal because I've
seen people that I've talked to on Xbox
Live and seeing people that I've talked
to you on Twitter people I've gained
with that is like that is like seeing a
bunch of different celebrities to me
like I saw mr. boomstick my I'd say my
mo some guy turned around goes hey ru
kelis what I recognized your voice cuz I
stand there talking to my wife and
talking to other people I it's so cool
like these I don't know this is my first
time meeting people that I've talked to
on the Internet
bad experience meeting people the first
time Miller I kicked him from the park
control I'm not gonna let you take it
imagine the moment of distinct the
twinkle in my eye and I got plenty of
straitjackets I got one for you too came
back here I don't know I just thought it
- it was fantastic and you listen I'm
telling I wish we could spend more time
first of all I'm really jealous that you
got a chance to hang out with Fonz
I really would like to hang out with fun
you know I really would love to watch a
UFC did that bring bill with it Fonz's
family you know what the fort alerted
you better wait for so long all right
but you guys can catch me at king of
statues as you can see that Superman is
right there in the back all right I want
y'all to make sure that you go to
Lourdes again with that net and and just
keep following us and understand this we
really we know these guys and we really
participating with them you know and
it's when I tell you that he is just as
genuine and it that'd be nice that's
real it's not a phony I see people put
stuff on the internet you know I'm not a
man you don't know the guy and he's real
and what he says he believes and 99%
stuff is true so trust me when I'm
telling you he's a great guy and I had
I'm so happy I'm I was looking forward
to this day long overdue like I wish I
had more time to spend with Kobe we're
out there man but it was good decade
even for my five minutes I had thrown my
hand through the VIP rope you get shaken
I gotta see you they said okay I got VIP
it was funny it was but I met Cole I can
say where you yeah it is always surreal
when you meet people that you've been
aiming with and just talking to over the
Internet and then you meet them you're
like you know you expect sometimes you
expect people to be fake right yeah even
though you know I'm Who I am here
we're live coke can attest to that we
met it's like I'm thinking maybe like
you always feel that with anybody in
your life then you meet him you meet
somebody like Colton you're like man you
spend five hours in and out you know it
was cold like I said boom Stig shot the
Ainslie ball it was a cruel man and all
right guys made great guys it just got a
chance to chop it up as much as possible
it's like a fraternity and it was good
it's really cool to see people who just
love gaming altogether you don't say
it's so salud that was dope man I mean
you already know what it is like
subscribe all the good stuff Lords of
gaming that night we got a lot of stuff
going on King said king of statues is up
please check all that goodness out the
stream team will be tomorrow they've got
a roundtable with the stream team my boy
old-school style is there gonna be a
guest on there so please check that out
Lord Peter Lawson although l-boogie the
whole stream today MJ is a boss
everybody in the realm and like I said
hit that like subscribe and we really
appreciate the support you know
everything everybody enjoy your Sunday
football is on if anybody got anything
else we are out and